All of the joy and excitement and fun that we want in life never comes from external
circumstances.
It always comes from the energy and the attention and the consciousness that we bring into each
and every moment.
So Laurie, I talked about this a lot and if you really want to solve this problem, I need
you to go read page 10 in my book Make Every Man Want You.
It's all about making is-ness your business.
So what does that mean?
Making is-ness your business means that you show up in each moment and you do this moment
like you friggin' mean it.
That means you bring your A-game.
That means you bring your full enthusiasm, your attention, your love to whatever you're
doing, wherever you are and whoever you're with.
Why?
Because all pain and frustration and annoyance in our life comes from resisting the moment.
It comes from saying this moment isn't how it should be.